obergrenze für hochzeiten und feiern
deutschlands landkreise fordern dass bei
privaten partys bundesweit maximal 50
gäste mitmachen dürfen proteste gegen
kohle und gas im rheinischen revier
demonstrieren tausende für ein ende der
fossilen energie und gedenken an die
opfer rechten terrors zum vierzigsten
jahrestag des anschlags auf das
oktoberfest warnt der bundespräsident
der rechtsextremismus habe in unserer
gesellschaft tiefe wurzeln
nachrichten nicht da das heute mit
christian sievers wir freuen uns dass
sie dabei sind der samstagabend im
überblick dieser nachrichten guten abend
dazu katja stresow kümmert sich heute um
den sport hallo und nennt und wieder ein
neuer höchststand seit april war die
zahl der gemeldeten neuinfektionen mit
corona in deutschland nicht mehr so hoch
wie aktuell die gesundheitsämter
meldeten innerhalb eines tages 2507 neue
fälle
das ist eine zahl die wir im blick haben
müssen das gesamte pandemie geschehen
ist aber nur durch eine vielzahl von
faktoren zu beschreiben und insbesondere
was die belegung von intensivbetten und
die todesfälle angeht ist deutschland
aktuell weit entfernt von der situation
im frühjahr bei den verantwortlichen
hier und bei unserer nachbarn steigt
aber die nervosität wie mein kollege
ralf schipp hans gezeigt herrlich weiß
beginnt der morgen in tirol hier wo
neuschnee genauso gebraucht wird wie
touristen
doch jetzt als risikogebiet geht die
sorge um
ja das ist ein schwerer schlag für den
wirtschaftsstandort tirol wir müssen so
rasch wie möglich wieder runter mit den
neuinfektionen damit wir von dieser
reisewarnung gestrichen werden
und wer eine ordentliche winters zu
haben werden aber auch in deutschland
zeigt der trend weiter nach oben
im sieben tagesschnitt haben sich
aktuell 1780 menschen neu mit kuwait 19
infiziert 20 mehr als gestern
derzeit sind es vor allem jüngere
intensivmediziner aber befürchten dass
wird sich absehbar ändern da sehen wir
im moment noch eine deutlich jüngere
population erkannte population
infizierte als noch im märz april 20
jahre jünger aber wenn auch das wieder
zunehmen wird und auch der virus sich
wieder in die eltern populationen herr
eingräbt dann werden wir auch ein
anstieg der schwer kranken zellen und
damit parallelisiert auch ein anstieg
der todesfälle
um dies zu verhindern fordern die
landkreise bei privatfeiern maximal 50
teilnehmer und dass das eine bundesweit
einheitliche obergrenze manche privaten
feiern haben ja zurückliegend gezeigt
dass darin eine riesen problematik
steckt nach meinem geschmack sollte man
die grenze von 50 auch noch
unterschreiten damit wir schneller
effektiv und wirksam ein pandemie
geschehen unter kontrolle kriegen können
von der csu auf ihrem virtuellen
parteitag eine ähnliche position für
mich als christ ist es ethisch nicht
vertretbar für das freizeitverhalten
fehler das leben einiger wenn auch
weniger zu opfern
am dienstag trifft sich die kanzlerin
mit den ministerpräsidenten zum bund
länder gipfel und dann wird entschieden
welche maßnahmen bleiben oder neu
hinzukommen und weitere zahlen und daten
zum pandemie geschehen auch ganz konkret
aus ihrem jeweiligen landkreis gibt es
jederzeit in der zdf- heute wegen corona
hatten umweltaktivisten eine pause
gemacht die erderwärmung aber nicht so
steht das auf deren spruchbändern und
plakaten im rheinischen braunkohlerevier
drangen heute hunderte in einen tagebau
außerdem gab es zwischenfälle in einem
braunkohle und an einem gaskraftwerk
denn auch erdgas schade dem klima immens
an seinem stern und heiko rahmens
rangeleien immer wieder heute im
rheinischen braunkohlerevier
es war ein ungemütlicher arbeitstag für
polizei und protestbewegung trotz des
regens trotz corona waren laut den klima
aktivisten etwa 3000 kohlegegner
gekommen aufgeteilt in viele kleine
gruppen die zentrale botschaft sofort
raus aus der kohle
wir machen das gerade jetzt weil das
coole ausstiegsgesetz bewiesen hat die
politik hat keinen politischen willen
irgendwie effektiven klimaschutz zu
betreiben sondern schreibt die
kohleverbrennung für 18 weitere jahre
fest einige aktivisten schaffen es bis
auf das garzweiler tagebaugelände andere
werden vom polizeiaufgebot aufgehalten
und vom abbaugebiet weg gebracht wir
beschützen den friedlichen protest dafür
sind wir auch da um den eben zu
ermöglichen
aber auch hier haben als im laufe des
einsatzes immer wieder szenen gehabt
wussten ja gewaltsam das
aufeinandertreffen mit polizeikräften
gekommen ist heftig umstritten ist die
braunkohle im rheinischen revier trotz
beschlossenen kohleausstieg will der
betreiber rwe den abbau hier bis 2038
noch einmal kräftig ausbauen
mehrere dörfer sollen dafür in den
kommenden jahren plattgemacht ihre
bewohner umgesiedelt werden auch deshalb
sind sie heute hier eine heimat oder so
zu verlieren
er findet das nicht schön widerstand
gegen die kohle und auch gegen
gaskraftwerke heute hier in düsseldorf
denn auch gas sei ein klimakiller sagen
die demonstranten die nach langer virus
pause zurück sind auf der straße ins
ausland im obersten gericht der usa ist
ein sitz frei nach dem tod von ruth
bader ginsburg der sie im kapitol in
washington die letzte ehre erweisen
traditionell entscheidet der präsident
über die nachfolge und projekt damit die
linie des gerichts oft auf jahrzehnte
aber darf er das auch kurz vor wahlen
oder sollte er mit solchen
entscheidungen warten bis die wähler
über die präsidentschaft abgestimmt
haben donald trump hat sich festgelegt
us medien berichten übereinstimmend
kunibert soll es werden 48 jahre alt
katholiken und offenbar gegnerin der
derzeitigen abtreibungsregeln in den usa
und wir gehen live nach washington zu
ines trams eines guten abend was würde
denn ihre berufung bedeuten für die
ausrichtung des gerichts in zukunft
juni bereit ist tief religiös äußerst
konservativ sollte sie an den supreme
court berufen werden und danach sieht es
derzeit aus dass das tatsächlich klappen
könnte dann würde präsident trump mit
ihr dort am gericht eine konservative
mehrheit zementieren sie könnte das
gericht könnte gemeinsam mit ihrer
unterstützung dann beispielsweise das
bestehende abtreibungsrecht aushebeln es
wäre eine konservative wende der
amerikanischen rechtssprechung vier oder
acht jahre einer möglichen trump
regierung wäre nichts gegen den einfluss
den dann dieses neue konservativ
besetzte gesicht gericht auf jahrzehnte
hin haben würde heute spät am abend will
donald trump seine entscheidung dann
verkünden die besetzung des obersten
gerichts hat ja für viele amerikaner
eine enorme bedeutung was heißt denn das
jetzt für den wahlkampf die frage ist
wem mobilisiert die frage oberster
gerichtshof stärker trank wird
sicherlich bei seiner konservativ
christlichen basis mit diesem thema
punkten können ihnen ruf da bereits
jetzt schon zu seht her ich halte meine
versprechen ich bringe konservative
richter an den supreme court aber auch
die demokraten ihrerseits sind
mobilisiert sie wollen liberale werte
verteidigen
die demokratische partei hat allein in
den vergangenen tagen millionen dollar
an zusätzlichen spenden einnehmen können
das gericht wird eine wichtige rolle
bekommen eventuell beim wahlergebnis
sollte präsident schamp das wahlergebnis
anfechten
dann liegt es womöglich am supreme court
ja über eine mögliche zweite amtszeit
von 5 zu entscheiden
in ist ramms mit hoher interessanten
hintergrundinformationen live aus
washington vielen dank
nach dem messerangriff gestern in paris
hat der hauptverdächtige laut ermittlern
die tat gestanden er habe es nicht
ertragen dass das satireblatt charlie
hebdo wieder mohammed karikaturen
veröffentlichte am ehemaligen
redaktionsgebäude der zeitung waren bei
der attacke gestern zwei journalisten
schwer verletzt worden
neben dem 18 jährigen pakistaner sind
acht weitere menschen in
polizeigewahrsam
frankreichs regierung stuft die tat als
islamistischen terrorakt ein
so jetzt in der sendung eine nachricht
bei der man sich ein bisschen die augen
reibt die autowelt kommt wieder zu einer
großen messe zusammen in peking eine
schau die millionen besucher anzieht
die chinesen wollen nachdem corona
einbruch im frühjahr wieder
wirtschaftliche stärke zeigen und auch
für die deutschen hersteller wird der
chinesische markt immer wichtiger
denn während europäische kunden wegen
der pandemie im august 28 prozent
weniger autos gekauft haben steigt die
nachfrage in china
nach dem großen einbruch schon wieder an
um rund 6 prozent gegenüber juli
stefanie schöneborn jetzt aus peking
die große autoschau in corona zeiten
die auto china 2020 soll hoffnung
vermitteln
es ist die erste große automobilmesse
seit beginn der pandemie die
besuchermassen ein ungewohntes bild
selbst in china von dem dramatischen
einbruch bis zu 80 prozent der
verkaufszahlen auf den chinesischen
markt ist an diesem tag kaum etwas zu
spüren vor allem die elektroautos sind
begehrt die technologie der elektroautos
ist toll auch die konzeptautos
für die deutsche automobilindustrie ist
der chinesische markt wichtig wie nie
zuvor
bmw mercedes audi vw porsche mit ihren
premium autos erzielen sie fast alle ein
zuwachs auf dem größten automarkt der
welt und bis ende des jahres rechnen sie
mit weiterem wachstum allein volkswagen
verkaufte 40 prozent seiner autos nach
china
experten sehen das durchaus kritisch
unser ruhe absatzanteil der deutschen
hersteller in china bedeutet einerseits
eine faktische abhängigkeit vom wohl und
wehe des marktes selber aber es bedeutet
eben auch ein stück weit eine politische
erpressbarkeit in diesem markt über
erpressbarkeit oder kritische themen wie
menschenrechte will an diesem tag
niemand reden bloß kein ärger mit china
also lieber daumen hoch für die autoshow
zurück nach deutschland heute vor 40
jahren der bombenanschlag auf das
münchner oktoberfest ein tag des
gedenkens heute und doch diesmal ganz
anders als bisher
denn erst vor wenigen monaten wurde das
attentat mit 13 toten und mehr als 200
verletzten auch offiziell als rechter
terror eingestuft in den 80er jahren
hatten die ermittler immer wieder
gesprochen von der frust tat eines
einzelnen das land bayern und die stadt
münchen entschuldigten sich heute bei
den opfern petra neubauer rote nelken
für die toten und gegen das vergessen
dimitrios lacker dinos hat beim attentat
vor 40 jahren seine damalige freundin
verloren er selbst wurde schwer verletzt
seine und die botschaft der anderen
überlebenden heute zu erinnern für die
zukunft
wir dürfen nicht zulassen dass
rechtsextremismus unser zusammenleben
vergiftet und bei jungen menschen fuß
fassen kann für uns überlebende ist
jeder tag ein 26 september
wir kennen ihn vielleicht einiges
verdrängen doch vergessen können wir
nicht am abend jenes 26 september 1980
explodiert am haupteingang des
oktoberfests eine bombe
13 menschen sterben mehr als 200 werden
verletzt
schon am nächsten tag sind alle spuren
beseitigt die wiesn geht weiter unter
den toten ist auch der attentäter
gundolf köhler ermittler sehen in ihm
lange den unpolitischen einzeltäter
trotz seiner verbindungen zur rechten
szene erst nach neuen untersuchungen
stellt die bundesanwaltschaft im juli
klar es war ein rechts terroristischer
anschlag
erstmals kommt auch der bundespräsident
zu dieser gedenkfeier und verbietet ein
weg ziehen die rechts terroristischen
mordtaten der vergangenen jahrzehnte
waren eben nicht das werk von verwirrten
die täter waren eingebunden in netzwerke
des hasses und der gewalt diese
netzwerke müssen wir auf spüren wir
müssen sie bekämpfen noch entschiedener
als bisher für die überlebenden gibt es
nun eine entschädigung endlich 1,2
millionen euro stehen zur verfügung
auch ein neuer gedenkort wird eingeweiht
er soll vor allem das leid und den
schmerz aus sicht der überlebenden
dokumentieren ganz anderes thema jetzt
große kunst ganz nah erleben in corona
zeiten nicht ganz leicht aber möglich
das beweist auch die hamburger
kunsthalle und präsentiert einen der
ganz großen der deutschen moderne max
beckmann
das ist eine ausstellung mit einem
speziellen blick auf die rolle von frau
und mann in beckmanns meisterwerken
christina hansen hat sich dass wir uns
angeschaut
wie er selbst gesehen werden wollte
daran ließ er nie einen zweifel als
ganzer mann kannte ich kräftig
entschieden
die hamburger kunsthalle zeigt nun auch
eine andere seite von max beckmann vater
brüchiger offener vor 70 jahren ist er
gestorben und hatte sich schon lange von
den gängigen geschlechter klischees
gelöst starke frauen waren immer wieder
sein thema der man oft nur eine
randfigur
heute ist er aktuell weil die frage wie
männlich sind männer wie weiblich sind
männer und frauen wie es unser
geschlechterbild und ist das abgebildet
da drin
das sind fragen die sich einfach alle
stellen die ausstellung ist auch eine
reise durch sein leben
traumatisch seine erlebnisse als
sanitäter im ersten weltkrieg
traumatisiert auch die gesellschaft am
ende des krieges hier nur als eine
weibliche welt im zweiten weltkrieg
emigration mann und frau gefangen
zwischen macht und ohnmacht immer wieder
das motiv lust und leid beide
geschlechter bringen um dominanz dieses
drehmoment in seinen bildern dieses
diese austauschbarkeit auch von opfer
und täter rollen das fasziniert dass es
fast in jedem bild in jedem motiv der
fall
das sogenannte schwache und starke
geschlecht bei max beckmann gibt es das
nicht diese sicht eines kantigen mannes
gibt es bis ende januar in der hamburger
kunsthalle
so jetzt hier in mainz für sie alle gibt
es den sport channel katja und wir
beginnen mit der fußball-bundesliga die
größte überraschung hat es heute im
augsburger stadion gegeben denn der fca
schlägt borussia dortmund am ende
verdient mit 2 zu 0 und ist damit
vorübergehend tabellenführer hier nun
das und die anderen ergebnisse vom
zweiten spieltag augsburg dortmund wie
gesagt 2 zu 0 gladbach und union berlin
spielen unentschieden 1 1 das ergebnis
auch zwischen leverkusen und rb leipzig
beide aufsteiger gewinn stuttgart mit 4
zu 1 in mainz und bielefeld zu hause mit
1 0 gegen köln
das abendspiel schalke gegen bremen
kurzfristig ohne zuschauer
erste bilder der partie im aktuellen
sportstudio bereits gestern verliert die
härter gegen frankfurt 1 3 und morgen
noch die bayern in hoffenheim und
freiburg trifft auf wolfsburg an der
spitze der tabelle der fc augsburg
mindestens bis morgen dahinter frankfurt
leipzig und aufsteiger bielefeld härter
und der bvb jetzt auf 7 auf 8 dortmund
freiburg und auch hoffenheim dahinter
leverkusen und wolfsburg am tabellenende
aktuell ohne punkte köln bremen mainz
und schalke
nachdem
deutlichen sieg seines vfb stuttgart
wird heute vermutlich ein gut gelaunter
vorstandsvorsitzender zu gast im
aktuellen sportstudio sein
thomas hitzlsberger kommt los gehts 23
uhr jetzt zur formel 1 und dem
qualifying zum grossen preis von
russland auch dort läuft das für ferrari
und sebastian vettel überhaupt nicht
mehr noch der viermalige weltmeister
kräfte in die streckenbegrenzung und
schied vorzeitig aus
sebastian vettels versuch misslingt die
physikalischen grenzen des ferrari zu
verschieben
vettel selbst bleibt unverletzt muss
sich aber sichtlich neu sortieren
ein ende mit schrecken mit dem
reparierten auto wird der 33-jährige
morgen als fünfzehnter ins rennen
starten fast hätte noch team kollege
charly claire vettels ferrari getroffen
der monegasse heute elfter
die ferrari krise setzt sich fort
tagesschnellster ist wieder einmal lewis
hamilton vor max verstappen und valtteri
bottas der weltmeister heute mit seiner
poleposition verschiebt derzeit die
grenzen morgen könnte er michael
schumachers rekord mit dem 91 grand prix
sieg egalisieren
nicht unwahrscheinlich die
niederländerin anna van der bellen hat
nach dem sieg im zeitfahren auch das
straßenrennen bei der rad wm in italien
gewonnen
sie erreichte nach 143 kilometern das
ziel auf der formel 1 strecke in imola
ungefährdet vor ihrer landsfrau anna mit
fünf leuten die sich im sprint um silber
knapp gegen die italienerin elisa longo
bottini durchsetzte beste deutsche hier
rechts im bild wie anne lippert auf rang
fünf und morgen sind dann auch die
herren der schöpfung dran freuen wir uns
den vielen dank katja was für ein
kontrast vor wenigen tagen in
deutschland noch sonne und teils
badewetter und jetzt grüßt auch hier der
winter auf dem feldberg im schwarzwald
hat es kräftig geschneit 4 cm neuschnee
das hat viele urlauber und autofahrer
überrascht kälteeinbruch auch in den
bayerischen alpen an der bergstation
haben osterfelderkopf reicht der schnee
für eine rutschpartie und wie lange man
ausrutschen kann das erfahren sie gleich
von katja horneffer der kollege claus
kleber hat das heute journal für sie um
22 uhr 45 morgen sind wir wieder hier
für sie darum 7 bis dann aber erst in
einer angenehmen abend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren das
tief karussell über mitteleuropa dreht
sich einfach weiter
dieses defizit weiter nach norden das
tief über deutschland zieht weiter in
richtung besten und das tiefe der
mittelmeer erreicht morgen bereits die
adria heute abend regen wir es kräftig
in deutschland und dieser regen breitet
sich im laufe der nacht weiter nach
westen aus erreicht die niederlande
belgien luxemburg und dann auch
frankreich und morgen früh ist es dann
fast in ganz deutschland erst mal
trocken
den kräftigsten regen in der nacht
erwarten wir aber in der westhälfte und
unter dem klaren sternenhimmel am
alpenrand sinken die werte bis 1 grad
deutlich milder bleibt die nacht an der
nordsee bei 14 grad und morgen erwarten
uns dann höchsttemperaturen zwischen 10
grad im thüringer wald oder auch im
westerzgebirge und 19 grad auf rügen
oder in nordfriesland und dann kommt
morgen der nächste regen er breitet sich
hier von polen richtung berlin
brandenburg mecklenburg vorpommern
südliches niedersachsen und nördliches
nordrhein westfalen aus es gibt morgen
aber auch eine region in der sonne und
wolken freuen sich mit einander
abwechseln
uns war hier südlich der donau in den
nächsten tagen geht es zumindest an der
küste recht sonnig und mild weiter und
mit dieser schönen abendstimmung von
gestern würde ich ihnen jetzt ein
schönes wochenende